but I actually think there's an
interesting business where you can look
at anything that someone is having to
spend a substantial sum today for
something that's going to happen in 12
or 36 months
and you help them uh guess the right
prediction
you can build an interesting business
and I'm going to give you an example
[Music]
okay so let's do it what uh what topics
you got today all right I've got one
idea based on something you sent me oh
wow we're rich
yeah but you thanks Sam you're having
one idea based on something I sent you
something put in the work today look I'm
in the final interview stage for my new
researcher
um but you told me last time you had a
lot and uh just hear me out so you sent
me this thing called exploding topics
right yeah
and you said their traffic's killing it
and exploding topics don't explain what
it is yeah it's basically like a if you
go to the website you'll see a series of
charts and the charts are basically
saying hey this um this thing this trend
is is growing in um in popularity I
think it started by which keywords were
growing in popularity because Brian Dean
who owned backlinko a popular SEO blog
got involved with it and then it kind of
changed to what it is now okay yeah so I
didn't know what the underlying what are
they looking at to tell you what's
trending or not but they'll be like um
you know hey there's this thing called
Power Dash It's a vacuum cleaner for pet
owners it's grown three thousand percent
right now right there but you know the
volume of that of that search is 320. so
not not huge regenerative agriculture
right uh growing 658 with 12 000
searches and you can look at that you'd
be like huh that's cool I'm interested
in that topic maybe there's something I
could do here so I think it's similar to
what trends was which was I will tell
you about things that are getting more
popular before they're fully popular in
order for you to take advantage of them
with content business that sort of thing
right that's the idea yes and the people
wondering Trends so basically I used to
own I sold it I used to own this thing
called trends.co and it was a weekly
email on an online community that people
would pay 300 a year for and we got it I
forget what it was when I sold it but I
think it was at like six million a year
but it very easily could have been like
a million a month or so in Revenue but
um basically we would send a weekly
email and we had three or two
researchers and they would comb the web
and five interesting things and they
would write interesting reports and they
would also include one to two Graphics
that showed like here's based off of
Reddit searches or based off of Google
searches or based off of like 20
different data points this topic is
growing quickly anyway
what uh exploding topics is doing
there's another another company called
meet glimpse so I think it's meet
Glimpse dot Co or.com I don't know and
this is just called Trends forecasting
and these versions of it including my
version they're what I would call
prosumer so people who just want to
spend
10 to 300 a month on it they're not that
big of a deal
but there's this whole other industry of
people willing to spend
25 100 000 10 million a year all on
Trends Trend forecasting and I think
it's a very interesting business model
and I think it's a very
under developed industry and so the one
that I brought up a whole bunch is
called wgsn wgsn it's basically a
monthly report that comes out and it
helps people pick which colors are going
to be popular what sounds trivial but
that's a really big deal if you're
Starbucks and you got to go and buy uh
10 million name tags or something like
that and you want to make sure that
you've got like a good color that is
like hit or for example wgsn do you
remember Sean how pineapple was popular
they helped predict that pineapple the
logo is going to be popular their next
one I think is the Lemon I think they
said lemon is gonna be popular maybe you
told me that actually and so anyway
that's what this does but I actually
think there's an interesting business
where you can look at anything that
someone is having to spend a substantial
sum today for something that's going to
happen in 12 or 36 months
and you help them uh guess the right
prediction
you can build an interesting business
and I'm going to give you an example and
uh let's just say that it's like HR or
like work Styles so what do we think
we're going to predict
um the work the the this particular age
group what are they gonna want for
working from home in the next 36 months
and if you're Google or someone that
employs 10 000 of these workers you're
like all right I kind of need an idea
because we're going to be making X
policy we want to know how they're going
to react
the way it could work and this is the
way wgsn and this is the way Trends and
a few other things work is you do a
combination of surveys so you survey
like you need a pool of like a thousand
or ten thousand people you can survey
and get Intel from and make predictions
then you look at like different data so
like you look at sentiment you look at
uh like what people on Reddit on Tick
Tock are saying just what trends are
saying and you consolidate in that that
into a fairly easy to understand 1 000
to 2000 word email that you send out
monthly
and then you have a consultant on staff
who you can call on a regular basis and
be like hey we're thinking about doing X
based off your research is that a wise
decision and then you have monthly calls
as well as a community and a conference
and I think you could wrap this up and
do it in most any industry and have
something that you could charge twenty
to fifty thousand dollars a year for and
this is something that uh what's his
name what's the bald head guy who I like
Scott Galloway he did this with uh he
did a little bit like this with his
company that he sold for 300 million
dollars what was it called it was called
uh L2 uh but anyway this is my model
that I think not enough people know
about and take advantage of that I think
could be pretty big
and uh I wish you had let me guess which
bald guy you like that could have been
back we could have gone on for a couple
hours on that one I have so many that
could have been the answer yeah Stone
Cold Steve Austin yeah
um what uh so what would you do so you
what was your what was your idea here of
like how you would create like a trend
says prediction type business what I
would do is I would I would package my
product in the way that I explained but
I think that most industries that you
work in you can figure out some type of
thing where you can look at your the
buyers of your company and be like or
look at any any different roles in your
company and be like hey everyone um can
I just talk to you and like figure out
like what decisions are you making
that's going to impact Us in like two
years and what type of data do you wish
that you had today that would make your
decision easier and I'm sure this exists
but one version of this I could think of
that's pretty valuable would be
if I could
pull like hey I you know we got a we're
able to survey every you know CIO in the
fortune 500. and you know we surveyed 70
of the cios in the Fortune 500 here's
what they're thinking in terms of their
software budget for next year or here's
what they're thinking in terms of you
know whether they per you know we HR
people at the at the you know top
thousand companies here's what they're
thinking in terms of remote pay or
here's what they're thinking in terms of
the XYZ and I think
if it's sort of like what GLG is uh
where exactly expert Network and people
will pay people like you and me two
thousand dollars for a one hour call
because they're making investment
decisions and they need to do research
and they need actual industry input to
say hey what's the deal with this I'm
not an expert at this you are but I need
to make a 10 million dollar bet and so
as part of my research and diligence I'm
going to pay you know you and 10 other
people like you two thousand dollars an
hour 20 grand no problem that's a that
that helps me make the right directional
bet here and so I think rather than GLG
being a one-way thing
um
I think you could do it as a
as a you know kind of like pulse survey
to as long as you had the right key key
audience that was bought in now how do
you get them to actually answer this I
think you could a just do it as part of
a broader like media thing like if you
already have an a newsletter for HR
people or whatever you could do it like
industry dive could do this
um I also think you could pay them and
so I think there's some some version of
payment rewards that that could go with
this because you're probably charging a
lot of money thousands of dollars for
these reports
um
but there is another business I want to
tell you from a listener here what's it
do called Eureka surveys so Google yes
yeah the bootstrap company yeah so these
guys if you go to Eureka surveys Utah
right it just says get paid for taking
surveys right make money online here's
how you do it and it's like these are
the small small time version of it so
basically you go you download their app
um let me pull it up
did he say we could say their revenue he
told me it but I don't remember they
told me once I think we could we should
just say it maybe generically but like
you know seven figures in Revenue
bootstrapped off this
um off this product idea and you know
kind of amazing uh kind of amazing that
they are
um doing so well and I I think that this
is like a really great business he
acquires I think in his case I think
he's going for kind of younger audience
sort of like you know gen Z Millennial
college students maybe stay-at-home moms
like you know more of the average
average Joe type of consumer and able to
survey them and they offer gift cards in
return like the brands who want to run
the surveys offer gift cards and it's a
great way to um
it's a great way to
you know get insight you know quickly
like for me if I have a brand right I
have a brand I want to run a survey like
this
um that's pretty
that's like pretty
um time intensive for me to go do so I
would need to go to a service like this
if I want to get an answer
well so that's my idea for for Trends
forecasting I think this survey once
interesting there's a lot of competition
in that space but I still think it's
interesting but that's like a simple
this is like a fairly simple
straightforward thing it's a lot of work
but huge business I think um all right
what do you got
um Okay so
I'm gonna tell you
um a couple names I'm gonna throw a
couple names out at you
you just try to tell me the pattern
Leonardo DiCaprio
Kevin Durant
Ellen DeGeneres
Luka doncic
George Clooney
you might be thinking movies you know
everything Sports and maybe celebrity
investing where am I going with this no
they all play Pickleball
pickleball is this crazy crazy thing
that is exploding it's not gonna be new
to most people here but I'm just sort of
late to the party I played for the first
time the other day when we did our kind
of weekend getaway for Founders things
and we played it's a lot of fun and I
was like I get it I totally get while
you guys haven't it took you that long
yeah I don't leave the house so it's not
an in my house activity so therefore
this is the first time I got exposed to
it right like
you know like I'm those people that that
like you know came out they're like
coveted what they don't know what's
going on
um that's what happened to me with
pickleball and so I started looking into
it and I think there's something
I think there's a bunch of little
interesting things I want to hear kind
of what you you find interesting this
but I'm gonna throw some stats at you so
my My overall take is pickleball is
exploding
um here's some opportunities I see and I
think it's gonna be huge it already is
getting huge but I don't think
uh but I see some potential traps and
I'll tell you what those are okay so
first of all just how many people in
America
this is a tough one yeah so many people
in America played pickleball in the last
year
20 uh no uh uh five million
it's a good guess 36 million so 36
million is a crazy number right that's
um
twice as many people as go to like
Disneyland every year it is that's the
population of California right so 36
million is a kind of crazy number right
that's like 14 of the of the total
population and
um and you can see this trend growing
right so that it went from 5 to 36 that
was in a one-year jump you can see on
Google Trends it's just up into the
right line
um you have celebrities like I said
earlier billionaires buying teams
leagues that sort of thing
um I personally know two people who have
built multi-million dollar brands in
this space I'm gonna tell you about them
so one one guy I can't say his name but
he built a Amazon FBA store
and this was two or three years ago he
sold it so he actually sold way too
early at the time I met him I was like
oh great you built a store doing what
I've never even heard of this sport
um and he was like yeah I just got into
it
um you know got really into it and so I
just thought oh let me just see if
there's much competition on Amazon for
this there wasn't so I built a popular
FBA store and sold it for about eight to
ten million and so this guy sells it for
eight to ten million dollars and I was
like wow you know you know highway
robbery
um you know tell that guy to lose your
number and now that he owns now that he
spent eight million dollars on this you
know pickle what you know what the hell
is this
I bet you if you had that thing now
that'd be a 40 million dollar brand you
know like this thing has exploded in
popularity whoever bought it knew what
they were doing
um the second is there's a guy doing a
newsletter called the dink so he's doing
the hustle or milk Road for pickleball
and we talked to him and we were like uh
we talked about we were doing oh I see
it the dink like d-i-n-k
and uh cool guy he's doing a bunch of
really smart things on the growth and
kind of like content side and he was
making more money per reader than we
were making on milk Road
we're in the crypto like Finance Niche
and he was making more money per reader
in pickleball than than we were because
he was hey he's executing well
um and Bae like turns out you there's
like you know there's a lot of people
who want to advertise and people who
want to buy stuff and there weren't
really very many mediums for them to
meet each other and this newsletter was
uh was that so this guy was yeah I think
this news was probably worth three three
million four million dollars today
um
so two people I personally know that
have that have done this okay and I got
a couple ideas here on I want to talk
about why this works
um where this is going and also just
some of the interesting characters that
are involved here uh you've played I
assume you've played yeah but hold on
before we I'm looking stuff up while
you're talking I've got a few I told you
so's that I want to bring up I was I was
looking this up as you were talking
episode number 147 this aired January
19th 2021 so almost exactly two years
ago
let's go to The Listener notes it says
uh
Sam brings up pickleball a booming sport
at Austin it talks about all the
opportunities there why he thinks it's
gonna be big uh
then you talked about dink I was like
that sounds familiar so I wish I could
can I share my screen right now I don't
I won't share my screen actually uh I
look up Dink founder it's a guy named
Thomas Shields I Google Thomas Shields
Twitter I go to his Twitter I click his
DMS and there's an unread message that
he sent me in
September 18th 2020. hey Sam Thomas here
nice to meet you
um I uh Eddie sent me a video on YouTube
where it's a custom video of him talking
to the camera saying hey Sam and he's
explaining to me about this newsletter
that he wants to start and he wants to
know if I want to participate in it or
something like that this is the first
time I've seen this video by the way I
I've not even I'm watching it for the
first time ever so
I was I take full credit for telling you
about pickleball I take not full credit
but it is cool that this guy hollered at
me and this is for three years later and
he's absolutely doing what he said he
was gonna do so man he's gonna respond
to the personal video huh
I well this is an unread Twitter message
I never saw it
but but anyway that so that's mine huh I
yeah well I remember seeing it but
Twitter's actually great because you can
open up a message and they don't know
and they don't know until you hit accept
and you could read the whole message and
some people like hey you never saw it
I'm like yeah
so anyway that's my story so you're
asking me have I played picklebor
pickleball before
and my my responses to that is does that
does Dolly Parton sleep on her back yes
I've played pickle pickleball before
dude of course I have have you seen me
have you looked at me I'm a I'm a tall
white guy from the Midwest of course I
play Pickleball do I like peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches
sure do am I taking a swing of a of a of
an old school Coca-Cola classic right
now sure yeah yeah you ever had orange
soda of course
um do you know how pickleball started by
the way
uh old people uh it was like a senator
or something right yeah dude you know
your [__] man this is crazy that's crazy
you know that
um it was a congressman so there was it
was a board congressman who created this
it was
1965. it was in the like the at the
Pacific Northwest and they get back from
some trip him and his buddy they have
nothing to do they're at this house they
have nothing to do they're bored the
house has a badminton court great let's
go play some badminton I guess they go
down there there's no equipment for
badminton they're like oh [__] what are
we gonna do so they're like well
we got ping pong inside but we kind of
be out I kind of want to be outside so
they take the ping-pong paddles a wiffle
ball and they go to the badminton court
and they start inventing this game
and they're just bored and they invent
this game and they're like they call it
pickleball because I guess there's this
phrase called pickle boat which is like
a hastily assembled crew for a boat and
they're like oh it was a mashup of we
just grabbed the paddles and played
badminton and lowered the Nets like this
mashup thing we'll call it pickleball
and so they create this thing it's like
you know just a small Regional game
nobody's really playing it and somehow I
couldn't figure out the link but like
somehow about
the last five years this thing has gone
like very very mainstream to where now
there are professional leagues there are
um you know tons of celebrities own
teams that their people are buying
garyvee buying a team Kevin Durant's
buying a team Tom Brady is buying a team
Patrick Mahomes is buying a team these
teams cost a million dollars now
um there are billionaires that are
trying to buy leagues and merging the
leagues to try to make this like an
official thing it has become kind of
real and
um there's people are trying to create
like Topgolf for pickleball so there's a
place called chicken and pickle uh and
Camp pickle that's trying to like
basically create venues where you can
come drink eat and play Pickleball and
so there's like this uh you know mini
Gold Rush that's happening right now in
the world in the world of pickleball and
I started thinking okay where do I think
this goes because I've seen this now a
couple times I've seen this with MMA
right going from Super Fringe to more
mainstream Esports
um and even some other things like the
Drone Racing League you ever seen the
Drone Racing League the deal quite yeah
that one hasn't picked up like I thought
it was going to but maybe it will same
same
um and so you see these happen and you
sort of think okay what does it take to
make these work and I'll give you I'll
give you what I think pickleball has
going for it and then I'll tell you what
I think is going to be tough for it so
here's what it has going by the way we
had a writer at a freelancer at the
hustle who quit for a year and she
became uh she wanted to compete in
pickleball and she did and she started
traveling to competitions yeah like it's
like an intense thing people love it
what did you say to her when she told
you what she was planning here
uh what do you think I said so that's
awesome
it's awesome
right now and then get out and that's
awesome yeah but it is awesome text me a
pic go after yourself
[Laughter]
awesome emotionally I feel a little
wounded and I'm rooted to fail
no but she did and she's doing good
um okay so here's what I think it has
gone for it so why like let's brainstorm
we've done this with food remember you
had your food thing that was I think
like low-key genius and nobody really
respects you for it except for me but
like I'm not such a left-handed
compliment look people don't get it I do
but no one else does no one else does
your parents don't understand but I'm
okay with your lifestyle we've talked
about it two or three times just to say
the joke again to see if it hits yeah
and it just doesn't seem to hit but like
let's do it again what's your food thing
and then let's let's do the equivalent
for the sports world so for food I was
like there's like a handful of
categories that you need to check off in
order to make your food go viral so it's
either going to be like a side food
where it becomes the main thing so it's
like instead of like ice cream that has
cookie donut it's like only cookie dough
the other thing is it has to be a
different uh color than normal so green
ketchup or rainbow bagels or it has to
be a different uh size so like a huge
pizza or a really small thing or the
last one was it has to be the
combination of two things that are
related but you wouldn't normally have
done it like the crow nut right yes
exactly again genius uh finally I
thought it hopefully you get yourself
this time
um so I think there's sort of a similar
thing when it comes to creating a hit
game or a hit sport because when I
played pickleball I was like okay that
was fun and here's what was fun about it
um
there's zero learning curve like we
literally nobody even really explained
anything they would just like stand here
and when the ball comes to you hit it
and then they were like there's two
rules don't go in the kitchen and like
you know whatever you know here's how
the scoring system works they told me
that as we were playing
um it was very intuitive it's like okay
cool got this paddle similar enough to
tennis similar enough to ping pong I I
kind of already know how to move my body
this way all right this will this will
work uh so zero learning curve
uh we were playing and the age range of
the players that we were playing with or
somebody had their son there uh you know
who I think is like you know 11 or 12
but I think you could basically play
this game from age eight to like 65. and
so everybody my my mom's close to 70.
she goes to her pickleball League twice
a week okay we only pushing this to 80.
uh you know I don't know how but this is
super broad range and how many sports
can you really say that for very very
few Sports can be played by extremely
young and extremely old people
um you could just play it with two
people so you don't need like five on
five or like you know a full football
team or basketball baseball team
um it picked up during covid because it
was kind of like an outdoors activity
that anybody could do that was sort of
socially distanced and so I think that
was like a big factor in white group
um and it's basically like a lightweight
version of of tennis
um or even maybe even a lightweight
version of golf in the way that people
use it because you could talk while
you're doing it you're not like just
huffing and puffing and running the
whole time and lastly and most
importantly you could play the game
drunk and so this is like you know if I
wanted to create the perfect game those
would be my my criteria and then you
know out would come would come
pickleball so I think it's it is kind of
a perfect game in that way so I think it
has legs for that reason I think it's
going to keep getting more and more
popular the fact that the whole state of
California worth of population plays
this game has played this game in the
last year is crazy
um and you also see other things going
for it like the founder of Lifetime
Fitness you know like the gym chain got
really into pickleball and then put 500
million dollars into building pickleball
courts in all of his like locations
because he's like I love pickleball
people are gonna love this and so he
deployed half a billion dollars into
building infrastructure dude I love that
and people are converting tennis courts
all this stuff is crazy there's 35 000
courts in the United States now dude
tennis sucks anyway only like a couple
people know how to play it you know what
I mean like my wife took lessons on how
to play it and I would go and play with
her and she would serve it at me and I
would basically just try to hit it back
and that was how he played it sucked it
sucks weird form of abuse actually is
what you just described yeah tennis is
stupid so to anyone listening who wants
to capitalize this We can brainstorm but
I'm going to summarize this in two
simple words okay
Vince McMahon if you are in this
business remember those words Vince
McMahon who's Vince McMahon Vince
McMahon is the owner and current or
former CEO of the WWE The World
Wrestling Entertainment I don't know
what it is but it's it's uh any time
that we grew up you know Stone Cold the
rock this is WWE back then it was WWF
dude when you think about it WWE is just
a bunch of ripped dudes in their
underwear having a soap opera in front
of 50 000 people and then the rest of
the people on TV it's all it is is a
soap opera and there's a little bit of
ripped dudes in underwear wrestling
that's all it is and it's awesome you've
got grown dudes who are like the most
like homophobic guys ever and yet
they're like sitting there watching two
oily rip dudes just rolling around it's
like you know they get past it all
because all they care about is the story
the drama this is all you need to do so
if you're interested in this uh you just
go and get a picture of Vince McMahon
you put a picture of him on your wall
and you say
what would Vince do yeah what would
Vince do ww uh VD what would Vince do
that's all I'd care about if I was
entering into this because that's
exactly what happens with tennis I only
cared about what's her name Serena in
that last like tournament that she was
in because it was her last one you know
what I'm saying like I only care about
this Naomi namasaka lady I only care
what's her name what's her name
Osaka I only care about her because like
I hear that she's kind of like going a
little like she's having some mental
issues and I'm like oh okay now I'm kind
of interested we got a train wreck yeah
like I'm into it and like that's like
when I get I get hooked on it or like
you know some of these like sports that
I don't think are mainstream I get it
like Lance Armstrong guy gets cancer
maybe he's on drugs killing these
Europeans all right cool you got my
attention like I need a story and that's
what anyone who's interested in
pickleball needs to understand
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
so I think
as funny as what you just said is I
think you're totally right I remember
when we started working on um an Esports
product right like that's what got
bought by by twitch we're building
basically an Esports company
and I met with a venture capitalist this
guy Zach we he goes love Esports
um but
Esports needs it's Dana White which is
basically Dana White was the Vince
McMahon of the UFC and he goes
Dana White he's like there is no UFC
without Dana White right because
literally the company was going bankrupt
uh so so you know I don't think
literally there would have been a
company without without Vance sorry
without Dana and his at the Fertitta
Brothers coming in and buying it and
putting in they bought it for two
million dollars and then they burned
another 40 or 50 million trying to make
it successful at a loss before it
finally turned around and started to
become a thing and so they put in years
millions of dollars and expertise at
promotion
um and willing to just run through walls
to make it happen going state by state
to get this thing licensed so they could
even host events and then hosting an
events figuring out how we're gonna sell
tickets and once they sell tickets how
are we gonna get this thing on TV once
it gets on TV how are we going to build
these characters in the story lines oh
we got to invest in all of these
documentaries and dude reality TV shows
and things like that before smartphones
were even a thing Dana used to give his
guys I remember you remember when the
these they first came out there are
these video cameras that looked almost
like an iPhone looks now but it was like
a flat flip cams he get he goes hey
everyone we're having a meeting you uufc
Fighters everything you do here's your
flip cam record it post it on like I
forget what was popular I think it was
YouTube but where he was like one of the
first guys to do that totally totally
was the first one and he had to do it
because he no mainstream channel would
let him in he couldn't get a you know
now they're on ESPN it took 20 years to
get onto ESPN as a sport yeah that
that's how crazy this was and so you
need somebody like that which is
basically just saying you need a
world-class
one in a billion entrepreneur you're
gonna make this work and there are some
interesting characters that are involved
in this thing do you know who this guy
is dundum if you hear about this guy the
search dundum pickleball
um there is this billionaire who is like
really trying to make pickleball a thing
like so this guy made his fortune doing
subprime auto loans
which like you didn't I didn't have to
say that Tom yeah Tom dundum yeah yeah
some prime mortgage loans uh like you
don't even have to say he made his
fortune if I just said yeah he worked on
subprime auto loans you'd be like oh so
he's filthy rich huh like you know like
there's no you don't put those four
words together without being a
billionaire and so he's super rich
he takes a bunch of big wild bets so he
put
I think like 70 million dollars into an
NFL competitor
um called the aaf that like basically
folded before it even had its first game
and he lost 70 million dollars trying to
do that
um now he's basically he owns
pickleball.com he bought the major
league
um you know the biggest uh league for
pickleball or like you know there's two
competing leagues and he bought one of
them and um this guy's like trying to
make pickleball happen and he's dude he
also owns the majority of Topgolf he
owns majority of Topgolf yeah he he does
a bunch of stuff like this so he is uh
pretty fascinating guy there's a bunch
of like really like interesting
characters that have like kind of pushed
this forward so he's one of the guys
who've pushed us forward
um there's another guy named Seymour
Rifkin you ever heard of this guy no why
would I have heard of him here are some
things about Seymour Rifkin self-made
millionaire by creating a marketing
company all right check
uh does Iron Man's check does ultra
marathons check Taekwondo black belt
check he has bicycled solo Coast to
Coast Check
he he created
um
the first rating system for pickleball
check he did all of this after the age
of 50.
that's pretty baller that's a that's a
pretty baller post 50 resume to have so
so this guy kind of uh you know pushed
pushed the the ball forward and kind of
helped legitimize it make it make it
more popular as well and then obviously
there's all the players and the people
who have been playing at the Grassroots
as well so so I feel like with
pickleball there's just like this
tremendous Groundswell and here's a
couple of my quick takes
uh first of all R.I.P badminton
I knew I knew for the first time I saw
badminton which was a little bit of a
big sport I could tell I saw it coming
and I avoided it like the play and it
just needed a little a little tweak a
little tweak there for badminton and you
know pretty sad for badminton it was
like sitting there the whole time and
missed this wave so uh you know that
sucks
um second could this happen again like I
need to go start playing all old people
Sports and just sniffing around like
what's up with bocce ball how do you
play this [__] is this good is this the
next thing like there might be another
old person sport that could be
translated down
um third you may not know this but I was
on the cusp of creating the next
pickleball
back when I was in uh Middle School me
and my buddies created a game called
golf
you might be wondering what's going on
and golf was basically the combination
of golf
and ping pong it was an extreme version
of big Punk and shout out to my guy
Steven who was there with me in the in
our game room and we created Golf and I
get I guarant this is the most fun game
ever and we invented it we just didn't
know how to commercialize at the time
um incredible game my version of that my
version of that was in eighth grade we
came up with the game called nutball or
you or
it's bloody knuckles with other parts of
your body oh no it's better it's called
nutball you sit 20 feet apart and you
sit on the ground with your legs yeah
and the person has to throw a ball the
first person that flinches loses
to get in trouble yeah my the Sister
Mary came up to me and said Sam no more
nut ball so I I got banned
which is the win of itself uh funny
story uh so I left you know we did that
weekend kind of retreat Founders thing
which was like okay we're gonna
brainstorm we're gonna really make plans
we're gonna you know think about what's
next we can give each other great
business advice
um I left early on the last day so I
missed the last 24 hours and so I hit up
Ben and I was like Ben how was the how
was the last day would I miss anything
good anything really you know do you
have notes you can share with me and he
goes now we basically just played
pickleball for seven hours because uh
suly really wanted to beat me in
pickleball and um he couldn't but he
wouldn't let me leave until he beat me
but he just couldn't beat me and so we
just played four and a half five hours
straight and I just picked up Non-Stop
and then after that we didn't talk and I
think like that's the sign of a great
game a game that could take over your
life and make you a bit of a degenerate
so I'm all in on pickleball dude they
need a leader with a good name when I
was in San Francisco I got into
competitive Skee-Ball and the guy who
ran it was called Joey the cat and he
you remember Joey the cat he braided
himself in San Francisco is Joey the cat
the Skee-Ball guy and people would rent
ski ball I remember him startups he was
just like renting out skeeball machines
to bars or to offices and started doing
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he was making
good money doing it right he was making
great money he owned buildings in the
mission yeah he owned like anywhere
where he had like a little Warehouse
with all the Skee-Ball machines and it
was Joey the cat and all of his uh
Skee-Ball machines had like a tiger
stripe on it and uh oh yeah you gotta
enjoy the cap machine that's great man
you you this it was like yeah you guys
you guys must be doing well you're
having you have fun in your office oh
cool like yeah oh you're into like local
[__] nice right right right oh you still
yeah you're supporting this local guy
show me the cat yeah wow you guys got it
going on
so this guy needs a the leader of uh of
uh pickleball they need a cool name like
Joey the cat
[Laughter]
tiger sound every time you say that all
right um okay cool let's do one more
topic okay I want to give you one more
uh interesting person
um that
I think is worth talking about okay so
have you ever heard of virtual gaming
worlds
no dude whenever we talk about this
what's my answer
well it's just kind of like a rhetorical
question really so go play sports
that's what I
that's what I hate me
um
remember about metaverse quests
no I'm not too busy having fun like I
beat up the last guy who said those
words to me
so go Google Google this company you're
going to be kind of interested in this
so okay go to this website and I just
want you to guess their revenue just say
we'll play a game called guess the
revenue
uh well it's just like a little
Squarespace Rinky Dink site looking I
don't know 5 million
uh close close three and a half billion
a year oh great with 500 million of
profit and they did this in 10 years so
what they do is they're basically
they're one of the only legal online
casinos in the United States they own
one of the largest poker sites in
America called Global poker and
basically it's casino games done via
sweepstakes and trade promotions that's
kind of like the legal Arbitrage here to
make this work is that they do it as
it's not gambling it's basically
sweepstakes
um
and they have a patent on it so they
have like very he has very little
competition at the moment apparently
um and I gotta give a shout out to the
guys so there's a guy who sent me this
message and a bunch of notes on this I'm
gonna shout him out real quick
um it's kind of uh
he was like dude you gotta feature this
guy he's basically a billionaire he pays
it like you know basically he he just
dividend it out you know in the latest
like whatever year recorder and just
bought a private jet off the off the
dividend it's like uh so shout out to
this guy Ansel who um
who told me about them so crazy crazy
business he's Ansel on Twitter
um all right so here's what here's
what's interesting so the guy who
started it he's an ex-financial planner
he basically was not a builder or a
seller right like the typical startup
archetype is like you're a great
engineer or you're the great growth
marketer and he was neither he was a
solo founder he was a financial planner
didn't know how to do marketing didn't
know how to do coding he was basically
just a badass and he recruited Mrs
Lawrence yeah Lawrence exactly uh he
paid a developer agency to handle the
build out so didn't have a technical
co-founder CTO just hired a Dev shop
um
you know it wasn't perfect like they
basically the code was so buggy like the
slot machines would accidentally just
pay you out a bunch and this happened
several times they had to like survive
that
um and this is built out in Perth
Australia so this is like built in the
middle of nowhere so kind of violates
all the rules single founder didn't have
the skill set wasn't in a big city where
you know oh you got to move to Silicon
Valley or New York or wherever to do
this uh he came to Silicon Valley once
couldn't raise any VC because they can't
invest in uh gambling opportunities but
the good news is this that means this
guy didn't take on any invest take how
much investment didn't didn't get
diluted so he still owns 66 percent of
this company that's doing 500 million a
year in profit and um and just you know
three and a half billion in revenue and
so you know it's a you know basically
started fully remote they got their
first office eight years in uh you know
eight years into the business it's
pretty crazy dude it says he um wow this
is amazing so he said they increased
their profit and they made 454 million
in profit and it paid dividends of 430
13 million dollars I actually have a
question so does that mean that the
company only needs uh 40 million dollars
or whatever the yeah 40 million dollars
in cash to operate either that or they
have enough cash reserves already there
to for whatever let's say their burn
might be 100 they might have already a
stockpile of cash reserves so they just
divided out the excess
that's wild man this is wild so it's all
based around this workaround which is
that the US law lets you do sweepstakes
um and you so they offer sweeps coins
that can be redeemed for cash and uh
they have a trademark around our patent
around sweepstakes trade promotions
basically they worked with the US
lawyers to build a system where
um like customers can basically buy
virtual gold coins use it to play the
games they have no value outside of the
game
um
but they when you buy the gold coins you
get these sweep coins with it and uh and
yeah basically like they found a like a
it was a regulatory Insight not a
product or marketing Insight that
allowed this
um to happen so and sweepstakes are
regulated basically like state by state
so in order for something to change
every you know different states each
individually would need to change
something in order to make this happen
um
and uh yeah there's basically like you
know brands that will use multinational
company like there's like sweepstakes
companies you can use to run sweepstakes
across States because of the of the
complication uh dude whenever whenever
people tell me hey I have an idea should
I hire a developer or should I hire one
of these agencies to make an app 99 of
the times I say no you're wasting your
money you're never going to do anything
with it and it's just going to go to
waste right this is the guy this is the
guy top Tower needs to jump on this guy
as like a story of how these things work
this is this is a really fascinating
story yeah exactly and there's a video
of him in 2012 he's pitching at the
launch conference to Jason calacanus I
don't know if it's this exact idea but
basically you know similar similar sort
of uh gambling idea and all the judges
are basically like oh you know the
opportunities outside of the US it's too
hard in the U.S and uh you know didn't
listen like knew his knew his [__]
understood that there's like a
regulatory moat and a a patent moat that
he could create that would allow him to
do this and based basically create kind
of like a small a not small sorry a
large Cash Cow
um that's essentially like on you know
nobody's really competing with them on
this which is kind of crazy it's
surprising to me that a patent would be
this this powerful at
um stopping somebody from competing
because in Tech
patents usually do nothing
um I don't care about patents at all
yeah whenever they say someone has by
the way what do you Conor McGregor nice
I like that word you can bring that back
yeah a little a little Brit yeah you got
to call me mate I like that uh that's
pretty good
um
they uh whenever I hear someone say they
have a patent like in a pitch I'm like I
I think that means nothing actually it's
a red flag I'm usually like that means
you think it's something and it is
nothing which means you don't know
anything yeah it's like asking me to
sign an NDA to hear someone's pitch I'm
like oh you yeah you're this is a joke
we uh I remember one of our startups it
was like um or like when we bought bibo
back
we got the patents with it and it was
like oh this is a patent for um like the
idea of like going on a social network
and whiteboard like there's like a
whiteboard feature where one user can
draw anything on this virtual whiteboard
blah blah I was like oh you invented
that he said yeah and I was like cool
but like I use that on Facebook he's
like yeah because this means nothing
this piece of paper means nothing and it
does nothing and like you know
impossible to really use this or enforce
this or like you know just way too hard
in the world of like internet Innovation
to to make this work it's that was my
that was my belief coming in so this is
a bit of a frame breaker here for me on
uh on like why this guy has no
competition doing this and it might be
some other reason there might be another
reason which is it might be that this is
actually Shady AF and like most
entrepreneurs don't want to do it or you
know there's too many lawsuits or
whatever
definitely that one by the way
definitely I I think it's definitely
that one without like knowing anything
about this and just going strictly off
uh like I guess with zero information
other than I see this guy uh owns a
bunch of Ferraris uh probably that one
oh his Instagram is prolific and you
speaking of uh of of names
this guy's got a name
Lawrence Escalante like tell you can't
be Lawrence Escalante and not have a
profile picture as he does where he's
like this at a poker table and he's just
looking over
yeah
he's them boys that's what is that's
what is his Instagram bio needs to be
just I'm them boy this guy's the this
guy's the guy uh well congrats to him
that's an interesting find he uh this is
a crazy story so yeah shout out to
Andrew that's uh he knew he's like dude
I got something that's
great for MFM and sure enough it was
yeah it's juicy that's what that's
called let's call it that's called a big
juicy burger
it's a good find by the way we forgot oh
I totally forgot speaking of the thing
legal agreements patents
important important contracts there's
one more
look if you've made it this far normally
we put this in the beginning this one's
for the for the real ogs you're into
this there's this thing called the MFM
my first million gentleman's agreement
and by the way Sean in our last video
you called it a gentleman's agreement
and then you actually said shoot we have
four women listeners we have to call it
a woman's agreement and did you see the
our four women listeners actually
comment in the YouTube channel and in
fact many said act no you have more I'm
number five but what they don't know is
that actually there can only really ever
be four for whatever reason it's just
like a law of physics or something like
that one in one out it's like a
nightclub and so we really appreciate
all of you all four of you are like near
and dear to our hearts
um we look forward to getting to know
you personally because we can because
it's four and so um and actually they
don't even need to sign the gentleman's
agreement
there's two requirements here if you've
made it this far in the video and also
if you've ever listened to more than one
video Sean and I dedicate like dozens of
hours a week to making these videos so
now you are in debt to us and all you
have to do to repay your debt is click
like if you don't matter if you're
listening on Spotify or iTunes or I
always call iTunes but you know what I
mean it doesn't matter where you're
listening to it you go to our uh our
YouTube page type in my first million
and then click subscribe and now we're
even and we work for you it's called The
Gentleman's Agreement because we're not
there I can't see your computer so you
just have to do it just don't lie so
please go and do that and that's it yeah
it's like um you know Biden was thinking
about canceling student debt well we're
going to cancel your debt you're going
to cancel all your podcasts then if you
just do this one thing like I mean I
couldn't couldn't think of a better deal
for you honestly so
um honor the gentleman's agreement go to
YouTube my first million click subscribe
and uh turn the notifications on too why
not
dude by the way this part of the Pod has
become a fan favorite yeah this is
really good and I have to say I stole
this from someone Jesse on fire I stole
this from him he's another YouTuber but
this has become a hit don't know why
you're admitting that I would just steal
everything and say that he stole it from
you
um and let the well he's uh he he's a
UFC podcaster so maybe he can kick my
ass and how does he travel I've never
heard it
uh he goes look the other day I went and
I saw the dish at 7-Eleven it was for
Alzheimer's or uh like muscle something
Dystrophy and I left a quarter there and
I didn't steal the other quarters I just
left that one quarter there because
that's called the gentleman's agreement
and I had to stand by it and that's the
same thing with this I edit the video I
come up with the content I do all this
work I do it for you what you're gonna
do for me is you're gonna click
subscribe that's that's our agreement
this is how Society works and right now
everyone's doing it and if you haven't
done it you're you're being left out so
please do that and that's his pitch it's
pretty good it's good and it's tough to
come up with it each time and I feel
like
in doing so we also earn our part of the
gentleman's agreement I'm making it
interesting right uh we gotta earn it uh
um we should uh we should wrap it we're
done
[Music]